bonjour à tous et à toutes
à l'occasion des élections municipales
sarkozy change de formule bertrand
carruggi mois nous recevrons en
alternance deux candidats par jour à
raison de cinq minutes par candidat nous
avons invité ce matin
dj golvet bonjour penchot mes favoris
vous êtes candidat à basse-pointe le nom
de votre liste lio nage points 3 vous
êtes technicien dé au service des eaux
et père d'un enfant
alors monsieur golvet dites moi pourquoi
vous vous présentez à basse-pointe
quelles sont vos motivations
alors c'est un groupe 1 il faut pas
minimiser le groupe au détriment d'une
tête de liste alors nous le groupe liant
nage quand on se présente à basse pointe
parce que la population a de grands
besoins a de grandes attentes
beaucoup de promesses ont été faites en
2014 j'ai fait partie de l'équipe et il
n'ya rien ne s'est passé comme on
l'avait promis on peut prendre beaucoup
d'exemples les promesses sur l'éducation
promesses on avait promis une
attractivité pour la commune 2014 il y
en a été fait la politique associative
elle est inexistante
aucune politique pour la jeunesse
environnement l'embellissement ya rien
c'est zéro équipements et être un des
infrastructures de la commune c'est ce
qui vous attend les souffrances oui
c'est ce qui vous avait faire 2018 jeter
l'épongé vous avez démissionné si ça
vous étiez dans l'équipe de marie
thérèse casimir yeux et vous avez
démissionné en 2018 si ça oui tout à
fait alors j'ai démissionné parce que
j'ai il faut bien expliquer à la
population qu'on fait partie d'un groupe
on en a voté pour nous on a fait adhérer
des personnes j'essaie de tenir comme je
pouvais mais pour nous la démocratie
pour il y en a je prends toi
la démocratie participative c'est pas un
vain mot c'est un des mots importants et
aujourd'hui c'est un de démocratie
participative
l'équipe en place c'est une monarchie
c'est une petite partie de personnes qui
dirigent la commune et voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de démissionner
j'ai essayé de résister jeune et j'ai
déjà lu j'ai jeté les planches quoi
alors quelle quelle est la principale
des marches vous allez faire quelques
elle qu'elle quels sont les axes de
votre campagne
alors les axes l'ap les axes en eux
mêmes celles axe prioritaire l'accès
prioritaire de votre campagne
l' axe prioritaire c'est un bien grand
mot
aujourd'hui on veut donner de
l'attractivité à la commune c'est
important ça veut dire quoi
l'attractivité à la commune c'est donner
du sens faire venir faire venir à basse
pointe aujourd'hui des partenaires
toutes sortes de partenaires
socioéconomiques des faire venir des
entreprises sur le territoire faire des
manifestations pour la jeunesse il ya
plus le martinique surf pro le
martinique soeur faut c'est justement si
l'équipe en place qui n'ont pas pu n'ont
pas su garder c'est un peu c'est une
malle à tracy voici une manne ou
l'attractivité des bordés d'attractivité
sur le territoire par rapport aux
matinées sauf pour beaucoup de
partenaires beaucoup de
socioprofessionnels beaucoup d'artisans
tous les restaurateurs de basse pointe
est en ébullition à grâce au faux et
l'équipe en place n'a pas pu garder ça
c'est dommage
alors comment redonner de la voix la
recommande de rendre le territoire
attractif en faisant quoi déjà refaire
venir le martinique sur frau ça c'est
une des priorités redonner du sens aussi
à l'humain aussi c'est important pour
nous il y en a ce point toi
de mettre en avant l'humain
l'association on a perdu aujourd'hui la
culture associative
on donne plus de subventions aux
associations une suprise associations et
pour moi c'est le poumon aujourd'hui
d'une économie d'une attractivité qui
manquent sur le territoire les points 3
reviennent aux urnes un an après des
élections partielles des élections qui
ont d'ailleurs confirmé marie thérèse
casimir yeux au poste de maire
quels sont vos réelles chances parce
qu'il faudra convaincre d'autant plus
lorsqu'il a ils ont aussi un an après
ils sont peut-être fatigués les points 3
d'aller voter chaque année fatigué non
je ne pense pas c'est comme ça que ça
devait se passer ça s'est passé comme ça
c'est juste pour souligner aussi la
démission de nombreux élus importants
ça veut dire que healy a réellement un
problème sur le territoire il ya un vrai
problème dans l'équipe en place monsieur
galvez j'ouvre remercie sa rocade est
terminé merci de nous avoir suivis